[Music]
thanks for being here thanks for having
us just unusual guests so many slackers
come on the show now they don't dress up
in the kids the kids in their pants yeah
the kids come out here with their
goatees and their jeans and they're like
dealing with winner hats and winners
yeah everybody's making fun of you when
you do that yeah
but it's like 98 you have a winner hand
on everyone's making fun of you just
know that stop doing they don't care
they don't care they're living in their
own world i want to first of all thank
you for being here we all work on the
same lot wb lot and i have to i have to
say something i asked for a while until
i found out it was your car billy i
would see your car parked and i would
say i didn't get you did i what's that i
didn't get it no no you didn't hit me
okay uh
but
uh but that was why i was here yeah
get him boys this is a sting operation
remember when you thought you hid that
hit that red
[Music]
have been scarecrow
you're like oh there's a red hair in my
bumper uh
this guy has the coolest car on the
warner brothers lot put up a picture of
this car that is a sweet
dreamy is that a 56 50 that's a 56 with
a 350 board piston double holley
carburetors what that is okay it's
pretty nasty i didn't understand a word
of that
it's for your gear head uh demographic
as well okay
i i bought that episode six you know
because i'm white trash and the first
paycheck i get i'm going to the car a
lot
so that's what i got you literally did
episode six is pretty early on
we got like four months of rent right
now
[Laughter]
now i want to ask you something like
that car that is uh
there's got to be some parts for this
night you use it every day it couldn't
be that practical my wife won't let me
drive it every day because it's worth
money so i have to drive it i get to
drive it on show days and table read
days so twice a week i get to drive it
and on thursdays i take my kid to school
yeah and it's
super loud yeah
i actually have been in my office and
heard it yeah and i thought we were
being attacked
it sets off alarms yeah we saw carlos i
have a thing with my crew and now
they're gonna the warner brothers
executives are gonna know but whatever
um
when i come in there's a couple parking
lots that are executive parking lots and
the camera guys always point to which
set of cars they want me to set the
alarms off on
you can just drive by and their alarms
go on i ride by and then put it in park
and then hit the gas and hold it it'll
set off those
that's ingenious that's fantastic
now melissa i have to ask you uh so many
you've been involved in so many great uh
projects what what's resonating most
with people if you're walking around in
the world and people come up to you
what's the thing they reference the most
well i get i mean i i get a lot of mike
and molly which is lovely
and then that's that's the good and then
and then i think
i think the one that's sticking most is
i got i get a lot of questions about um
a particular scene in bridesmaids
what scene what scene would that be
there's a scene where i may be
sitting upon a sink
yeah yeah and we were we were do you
remember uh mike and molly they were we
were shooting a basketball scene and i
sat down next to a really lovely fella
and his first question he's like
i gotta ask you
did you really
and i was like what what
and i was like oh he seems lovely we're
gonna have we're gonna have a nice
conversation and i leaned i mean i
leaned right into it i was like yes
bailey's just like come on man
that's the most insane question for
someone to think that was a real one i
had to answer it so now i'm like and
then i'm over talking and i'm like no
you know in a movie you're never and i
was like just say no and move on instead
i'm like i couldn't dig my way out of it
i was like no honey you should have made
his dream
and now barbara walters can't ask you
that question